well they're complicated for the White
House but they're one that they feel
like they've got the upper hand on and
you heard the president in his remarks
today announcing the official opening of
the US Embassy in Havana the Cuban
embassy here in Washington DC pointed
effective public surveys public opinion
polling across the board both parties
leans towards the White House on this
and I think that has been won in large
part one of the key reasons they were
willing to go through with this they
felt like the time had come as the Obama
administration has said over and over
again the policies in general have
failed they've moved forward it's been
about six months since they initially
announced they were going to start this
process to get to this point but one key
point here mark there is still a lot of
work to go as they try and move forward
on diplomatic relations speaking of work
is also money involved Phil because of
this embassy the US Embassy has to be
reopened and upgraded funds for that
must be allocated and those funds have
to be allocated by Congress and from
what we were hearing after today's
announcement by the president that's
going to be a tough task that's exactly
right mark look there's few mechanisms
right now that Congress can use to
actually try and hold back the
administration here and it's important
to note Republicans in leadership
speaker john boehner Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell senior
Republicans top Republicans like Marco
Rubio have stated they're very opposed
the administration's moves here and the
appropriations process is one way that
they think they can try and hamstring
what's going forward right now now it's
important to note the Obama
administration isn't purchasing or
building a new a new area to house their
diplomats they actually have a mission
that's still down there the same mission
that was used as the embassy in 1961 all
they'll be doing is repurposing it and
changing the name another key issue mark
on this area that you need to look at at
some point the Obama administration is
going to nominate an ambassador to Cuba
he will also have to go through the US
Senate where there are not only
Republicans that have problems with this
issue but including key Democrats like
Senator Robert Menendez who again said
today he's very opposed to this
direction the Obama administration's
taking it might be willing to try and
block their own nominee Phil about 30
seconds left I'm struck by the date July
twentieth that's the anniversary of
man's landing on the moon are we talking
one small step for man one giant leap
for the u.s. and Cuba here you know the
president said today a year ago nobody
thought we would have been in this
and I think that's very true a lot of
behind-the-scenes negotiations including
the Pope during this entire process I
think for the administration's
perspective this is a key legacy piece
one that they had been working on behind
closed doors and weren't necessarily
sure they'd get to they like where they
stand on this and they think they're on
the right side of history on this one
mark